on Tuesday Tesla's stock hit a 52-week
low in early morning trading pushing
Elon musk's Fortune down to an estimated
195.6 billion dollars as of 10 a.m
Eastern Time
it's only the second time since October
1st 2021 that musk has been worth less
than 200 billion dollars his net worth
dipped to 199 billion dollars on May 24
2022 before quickly rebounding though
musk Remains the world's richest person
he's more than 74 billion dollars poorer
than he was on April 13 2022 the day
before he went public with his 44
billion dollar hostile takeover bid for
Twitter by the time musk was forced to
acquire the social media company on
October 27th after trying to back out
for months his estimated 82 stake in
Twitter was worth nearly 40 percent less
than what he paid for it according to
forbes's estimate based on an index of
publicly traded social media companies
luckily for musk he amassed a 9 stake in
Twitter before he announced his offer to
buy the company when share prices were
already low and he was able to fund part
of the acquisition with 13 billion
dollars of debt on Twitter's balance
sheet rather than his own those moves
helped him stem losses on the deal In
fairness to musk other factors have been
weighing on Tesla's stock price in
recent days the prospect of a new
republican-controlled Congress after the
midterm elections has investors worried
about clean energy stocks new zero
coveted lockdowns in China have also
weighed on the car Maker's stock adding
insult to injury it was reported on
Tuesday morning that Tesla recalled 40
000 cars over a possible steering issue